hey I'm Danny Philippa and I'm Michael
and we're about to break down a scene
from our film talk to me and I apologize
for the state of my hair
[Applause]
we've always been uh
drawn to the supernatural I don't know
if we necessarily believe in it or not
but I'm always interested in hearing
people's Supernatural experiences or
staying in a haunted place you know if
someone says this place is haunted I
want to stay there and experience it see
if there's that that'll attack me or
something like that so it's always
something that where we've been
fascinated by
um so the idea of a hand it's like what
would be something that people would
want to experience and I know that I
probably would as well you know if it's
that hands there you can connect to a
spirit sign me up the hand is a physical
representation of the themes uh the film
is about Connections true ones and false
ones and the hand is a false connection
and Mia wanting to do the hand in this
scene is you know she wants to connect
to something to feel something she says
a friend connecting with her love
interest she must have feel something
let's do the hand and connect to some
yeah yeah the hands are a big Motif in
the film there's a lot of hand shots a
bit of a hand fetish you have there was
a lot
okay
talk to me
well yes the spirits the people that
play the spirits is like I feel bad it
was like because it was in the middle of
the uh the pandemic right and uh so they
had like quarantine and we're getting
people from interstate so like say like
yeah this lady she'd come for three days
quarantine be on set you know for that
day be on camera for like half an hour
and then do three days quarantine to go
home and the man the old man that we
filmed like that that's in just before
that like that poor guy he was on set
for 10 minutes and like he had to
quarantine for a week to be in there he
shut down like well I can't got it he's
like oh okay and then like yeah traveled
all the way there for like half a second
on screen yeah I didn't even know we
were rolling just sat down and then I
had to go you know but it was like it
was like important for us to not linger
on those ghosts too much and like have
it be from all the positions in the film
are all told from Mia's perspective so
she's seeing it for a second and she's
turning away like we're not gonna let
the audience Linger on it like all of
those shots and the possessions and the
ghosts are all told yeah yeah it's all
grounded from her point of view so even
uh you know know scenes outside of that
you don't see the spirits only what
she's experiencing yeah um but yeah yeah
the makeup she did an amazing job on on
almond spirit's name uh yeah the the
drowned lady yeah and we also signify
that with uh the breathing and the sound
design whenever that spirit is on screen
so like uh when Mia is possessed in that
first scene she's breathing like she's
breathing in water and and there's
always yeah there's always water around
yeah her scenes when she's possessed by
that spirit
say it
[Music]
I let you in
so the room that we'll shoot again was
so hot and it was like everyone was
delusional in there and we had Sophie
sit down in this makeup and she was
doing hours of position and we would go
through so many different Alternatives
and like she would give us so many
different variations so the point where
she said she felt like she'd lost their
mind and she was just riffing and
talking and like yeah you could sort of
Capture Me sort of captured that where
she there were lines that she had to hit
and then there was times that we would
like break off from that and like I
don't know we're just encapsulated her
Insanity in that very hot stinky room
got it
[Music]
there you are
so if you said talented she's uh playing
uh you know a character that's possessed
by another character and also you know
the camera movements were quite specific
to uh what she's experiencing and the
camera's revealing things as it's coming
around so she had a lot to like think
about but um that's just how talented
she is as a performer that is she able
to hit all those beats from a
performance point of view and also
leaning into you know uh the camera side
and and the visual side as well so she's
yeah she's able to do everything at once
um and she was there for a long time she
had those big scleros in we wanted them
to be practical you know uh we want to
do it VFX because you know if you can if
you see bad VFX it really sticks and VFX
tends to age no no but there is a cool
subtle V effect if you look very closely
after her head tilts back you can see
her iris is growing which we did in
there so like throughout the scene she
gets more and more like uh taken over by
the spirit and you can tell the
progression of that through the makeup
on her face and the state of her eyes
yeah it's like well yeah using practical
merging with VFX is the strongest we
feel so we try to do things as
practically as possible
um with makeup and uh effects and things
like that and then you kind of uh you
know more them together with VFX so
they're working together I'm not just
like oh this one's going to be fixed
we'll sort it out in post another thing
that happened is when she her head tilts
back we initially had her hair waving
like it was underwater we had 3d hair
like a really awesome effect in the VFX
house kojo did such an awesome job of it
uh but it just took us out of the
reality of the scene because it felt too
heightened and up until that point the
film had been so played realistically
that like if it went too crazy too quick
I feel like the audience would be like
oh this is a movie we just wanted to
yeah really be in that experience make
it feel as real as possible with the
possession scenes and you notice it in
this first one there's a difference in
sound and camera movements a lot more
floaty uh and also yeah with sound
design we wanted to show that you know
we're here but we're not here it's like
a different way in a different kind of
reality we're separated from reality a
little bit here we're on on the spirit
side of things so there's things that we
did with Sound and Music and
um our performance and Visually that
signifies when we're when we're in
possession mode or in spirit world mode
so we wanted the camera to sort of be
anchored to the spirit that was inside
Mia so all the movements are the things
that are happening inside the room like
the door slamming like the camera is
reacting to the energy that that spirit
is putting out there uh we also wanted
it to feel as if like we're circling and
looking at things that aren't there but
they are actually there in the spirit
world so like meerus pointing at people
that we can't see in the room but are
actually in the room so like
realistically in that room right there
there's probably about 10 15 Predator
spirits that are surrounding this boy
that have picked him we want that kid
and it's not the spirit's point of view
it's Mia's point of views that's why you
don't see them
current and what would happen
a horror scenario in today's setting
with phones and social media and it's
because it's a world that we come from
it's like uh we have a kind of an
understanding of you know how it might
work you know if it was if the ham was a
real thing so we wanted to bring so
there's no way it wouldn't go viral yeah
you want we want to bring someone as
current and uh and back to kids these
days that would understand so that
that's what like yeah what would happen
if you were able to film and upload
everything what would be the reaction
now because back in the day it's don't
walk into the dark Forest but now let's
do that and film it and get attention we
have that attention-seeking thing about
us now it's like we all just want
attention we're all posting on tick
tocks doing you know we're doing
whatever we're doing to try and get
attention whether it's good or bad so
it's showing you know there's a positive
and a negative to that um and we wanted
to show you both sides of that in the
film